your insurance agency the sponsors of
this next segment are stressing the
importance of broker relationships and
the difference between local brokers and
agents we talked with an expert for more
take a look
hello and welcome back to your insurance
agency today we're at the meadows mall
and my name is chris carruthers
president today we'd like to share with
you the difference between a broker and
an agent
so the difference between a broker and
an agent is an agent is one who works
for a company they're interested in
selling one product or one carrier's
product line a broker works for the
consumer or our clients the difference
is we can shop the market and find out
what plan is best for you i'd like to
introduce you to one of our brokers
virginia mckenzie
so what does a broker mean to you
well at one time i did work for a
particular company and i was happy to do
that it was a good company but i only
represented their plans
and other plans came to town with other
options and i felt like i needed to be
free in order to match my clients with
what i felt might fit better
so i became a broker and i've never been
sorry about it it's wonderful to be able
to really help your the clients that
need you with options that are right for
them
virginia that's one of the great reasons
why we love partnering with you as what
broker is how you care for your clients
and that's what we stand for your
insurance agency
so one of the tools we have now going
forward to help serve you better is we
have now have an enrollment platform i
think of it as a calculator where we can
take your basic information plug in the
system to help you determine what plan
is best for you so one of the things we
now have to do because of this new
technology
going forward we now have to record
telephone calls
so whether you call in to us
or there's a zoom call
be aware there's going to be a message
saying your phone call is now being
recorded so don't panic it's just part
of what we have to do so if you are
uncomfortable with the phone call being
recorded feel free to contact us and
come into one of our locations just like
virginia
she's at walmart's as well as at the
mall or go to our website and you can
look up a location that's convenient for
you to pop in and get some service so
when i meet with somebody whether it's
at the meadows mall or at a walmart at
the walmart i'm at
or even have an in-home appointment they
requested that i don't have to record
that one
but i do try to educate them on what
their options are under medicare as far
as the supplement or the medicare
advantage and i get information from
them on what their prescriptions they're
taking because i can provide a
projection of what those prescriptions
are going to cost with different plans
and also what doctors are their favorite
do they are they willing to choose
somebody new and have somebody new look
at the situations that they've got or do
they want to stick with somebody and
provide a network that includes that
doctor or a new network that's got
they're going to be the focus of for
that client so i try to match all of
that for them and it's very personal
and you don't get that if you answer the
phone call and somebody's calling you
about medicare and changes you in plants
i agree with being careful of the 1-800
numbers those people are there to just
enroll you and plan but that's it
they're not there to service you all
year long like you're willing to do and
our brokers are willing to do
thank you to your insurance agency for
sponsoring this segment you can give
them a call at
five 702-425-5555 zero or visit y i a lv
dot com for more
[Music]